I
so I asked bud meat for the privilege of
announcing the next speaker by me I
things been doing a fantastic job in
this room all day I'll pass this back to
him for QA but I just want to say it is
my absolute pleasure to announce our
next speaker so this is I believe Souls
fourth pythonic conference his first
talk was at PI data Boston with me and
then we did New York in Silicon Valley
and now Berlin so I think we owe him a
big round of applause he's one of the
regulars and if you come to PI data in
New York this fall I'm sure he'll be
there too Thanks thank you James okay so
speed without drag first of all if I a I
learned something from James Powell here
is that you can't ever talk too much
about yourself so al I'll talk but i'll
talk a bit about me first I am a
Spaniard in New York the songs not the
same it's a bit crappier but the accents
better I had to resort to musical jokes
because the soccer jokes I had turned on
me this year but at least I'm not
Brazilian my background is in
electronics and CS as well and I've been
doing Python for four years now first in
at Tech and ambushed in facebook
advertising sort of salt less work but
really interesting technically and then
at think for teaching people how to how
to code how to build websites and apps
which is much more fun you can I contact
me at that email address you can tweet
at me at definitely and you can go to
github if you want slides the the
ipython notebook that's behind the
d slot dis reveal Kenya's slides so
what's the story what are we talking
about today the story for this is not
about you guys but I really like Python
if I have to write code James likes
Python see if I if I have to write code
I brother I much rather write Python or
anything else so you know every now and
then you bump into something into
someone that says oh you can't do that
in python python is just too slow who
here has heard that before yeah who here
has reacted to that quite aggressively
okay by the end of this I hope you you
live displays with enough information to
react aggressively to you to that stage
so disoriented pro likes JavaScript a
lot like JavaScript telling you how slow
python is and how crappy python is and
that's what we're willing we will try to
to counter argument and in particular
we're going to talk about numerical
Python code because that's what pie that
is all about right when we really how to
speed that numerical Python when we
really don't want to waste time or we
don't want to write siphon or see
modules or stuff like that but before
now that I kind of pack your interest
hopefully I'm going to tell you not to
do it I'm gonna tell you to think first
cuz there ain't no such thing as a free
lunch and there ain't no such thing as a
free speed up you're going to have
deployment problems maybe you're going
to have overhead to onboard other
engineers into your project you're going
to have all these problems if you use
some of the tools rule percent today so
think first and you know if you can get
away with
just don't do it don't don't even try it
what if instead you think things through
and refactor maybe you can do that or
you know this Jeff Bezos a most favorite
way of solving things you just throw
money at a problem you buy more servers
you it basically waste resources you can
also evaluate other things you could be
doing in that the time it will take you
to implement these things and you can
also limit on the kill van rossum switch
to Java well we're going to skip that
part because I want to come back here
next year all right so how what are we
doing here how how do we speed Python up
but then again I'm let's let's let's
think first on other ways of not using
this this this tools as libraries before
we go and try to use numb exper on
something we have to figure out if you
know we have a io problem somewhere if
we were serialize endure serialized in
somewhere Ellis we have any other
bottleneck that's not computational this
this stop wound won't help you so figure
that out first make sure your coats not
doing stupid things such as calculating
something over and over some developer
that I might or might not know or might
or might not be was compiling on
Reddick's repeatedly not too long ago so
try not to do those things discard are
you discarding any computation meaning
it don't calculate precision if you're
not going to use it if you're going to
floor a number on them don't calculate
the entire thing different types of
randoms have different speeds how much
entropy do you really need many other
things there's a link here to attack by
David chat shotta
that's a good one to say here schacter I
think he's a lead engineer at Disney he
gave a really good talk last year on how
to speed up some problems different kind
of focus his focus is actually due to
like work that you know deal the old
timers I guess and it did but definitely
interesting to watch and then of course
in C Python captured the low-hanging
fruit try to use multi-process in take
into account the overhead and and
Amdahl's law which is really present in
Python as you know he's a miracle
objects if you can careful with
temporary values use try to use things
that we don't use in Python like slots
fast append comprehension generators but
you know if you use generators don't use
his code but again this is not the point
of talk it's a Python conference so
we're going to talk about how to do PI
data solutions to to to this problem so
we're going to go through a list of
libraries and tools that will help you
circumvent quote-unquote the safety of
Python because in reality what we're
doing when we are speeding things up is
either jumping out of Python all
together whether or not we're actually
doing the work ourselves if you are
using numpy you're basically using
someone else someone else I wrote in C
right or Fortran so for that we have
many tools such speed it's amazing this
talk was written in February of this
year and the memes are already outdated
but anyway we we've talked about
exhausting pipe C Python we will go over
numpy number parky nomics / see a new
pie pie pie pie Jeff own place pi stone
and
bathroom and to do that and to make it
slightly less boring we're going to use
the drive an example which is a one of
my favorite interview questions which is
building a function that calculates the
area of polygons given its coordinates
nothing too crazy and before we would
get down to it finally person disclaimer
we're going to be doing a lot of time in
it and a lot of timer stuff there's
value in the in the measurements but
they're not gospel they're biased the
problem itself the driving example is
what it is so it's obviously a as I say
reductionistic tool to to figure out
which works and what doesn't which means
some some of the tools and libraries
might not do that well for this
particular problem that doesn't mean
they're not valuable but that just means
that you know they're not the best tool
for this particular problem and of
course again we just have one bank
benchmark so don't [ __ ] don't focus too
much too much in the under numbers with
that I'll show you how I did how I
solved my own interview question which
is something as terrible as that this is
the diagonal polygon generator which
will basically generate coordinates that
for a polygon that looks kind of like
that diagonal we have up there the code
is terrifying really I don't like it at
all but it does the job when you write
code as ugly and we're looking at this
if you're James Powell you make it a
presentation and tell people not to use
it if you were me you test it and you
call it production ready so that's what
we're going to do and then there's the
the solution to the actual math problem
under underlying math problem which is
basically getting the the sum of the of
halves of all the two by two the sub
determinants and coordinates this is
basically a shoelace formula for those
interested which is basically a corner
case of greens theorem which in turn is
a subset of Stokes theorem basically
what we're doing is multiplying
coordinates x 0 x y 1 and that so
nothing too crazy anyway it says this
too it's tested too and this looks
somewhat better so we're going to go
with this and if we create a diagonal
polygon that's 200,000 levels tall and
we run that solution we get half a
second or one-fourth of a second in in
time adding in ipython so does that the
first thing I talked about was site
sci-fi sci-fi as you know is its stack
it's an ecosystem it has things as
amazing as I Python numpy pie tables
lots of things and then it's it's own
library or the own original sci-fi
library in sci-fi we basically have none
pipe which as you know it's the N
dimensional array implementation that's
basically part of sci-fi but it's also
its own thing so what happens if we try
to use numpy to to solve this problem
here the only thing we do is we create a
polygon that's the we translate those
coordinates into a numpy rape and then
just an umpire solution for this is
basically the same we're using the same
formula only we're using vectors and
using vector operations directly just by
doing that we have well we go from yeah
what's that like 30 25 25 X improvement
so that's that's pretty good we really
didn't do anything next comes numbaa
numbaa summers you some of you might
know is just in time compiler that
leverages llvm and translates a subset
of Python into llvm I are too you know
farther leverage the yellow BM compiler
in and just in time switch your your
code 44 dad binary bytecode I guess
there's experimental support for CUDA
static compilation and then multi-core
in n GPU support that's a freemium model
I guess it's made by the continuum guys
that are around here so if you have any
questions about it I'm sure they can
they'll be happy to talk about it as
James were saying we gave a talk in
Boston about numba so if you're not
already tired of me you can go online
and watch that one too so number number
has a really simple API it's basically a
turnkey solution where you don't have to
do anything if you if you don't want to
the only thing you do is either decorate
the function you want to speed up or you
know wrap it in in the in the numbers
chip and you have your numba function
and just by doing that sometimes you get
speed apps in this case the Python the
naive Python solution does slightly
worse and the new empire version
it's slightly improved but not by much
that is not to say that numpy is
worthless fraught far from it you can
find examples online off numbaa doing 15
1500 X I improvement in some algorithms
just didn't work in this case unrelated
to to our driving example I wanted to
show you something else in new mode as
that's pretty powerful which is
vectorizing functions you can create a
function the same way you can vectorize
the function in dump I to apply using
broadcasting to to a vector you can do
it as well with numbaa only num pies
vectorize was never supposed to be for
Speed it was just basically a nicety a
helper numbers vectorize will speed up
things a lot in this case we see how
multiplying something by itself and
adding one gets sped up a lot for TX and
the benchmark with numpy is closed we
got to realize that new pi square is
optimized and this is a really simple
function I chose to for example as soon
as you start doing something more
complicated numpy won't probably be able
to to follow the Numa vectorized
function so there's that that's pretty
interesting next stop is parakeet Park
it was originally pretty similar to to
number in it goes although the
implementation that was pretty different
as of late it has taken a turn they
basically deprecated the llvm back-end
and are focusing on c and open MP there
they are also implementing some
functions manually so it's less about
inference and
more about actual optimization of of
certain things experimental support for
kuta as well i haven't tried that so can
speak about that but for our driving
example the api is exactly the same or
fairly similar to two numbas and it's
sort of the this the same thing with the
naive Python version which you know
doesn't work I'm I assume it's old r ay
axis but for the new pipe for the new PI
version we get a speed app so we go from
an original figure of nine milliseconds
for limp I down to 1.2 11.3 so that's
pretty good and again we did nothing
nomics / front desk I'll tell my fellow
countryman is here and he gave a talk
earlier in the same track that included
no expert but for those of you who
missed it new mex / is a library that
helps you optimize the way vectors go
into the into the processor and break
them down into the same size as the cash
so that everything's used up Adam in the
best way possible it avoids intermediate
values so less less storage used and
thus speaking you get speed improvements
and end our support for OpenMP and the
vector vector math library in the math
kernal into some low-level
implementations it's a reduced set of
instructions it's not Python you have to
it looks like Python but it's basically
a set of expressions that are evaluated
but it's highly performant in our case
other than getting the columns of the
matrix in separately the only thing we
do is we we defined again vectorized
operation and when we evaluate it we go
from again nine milliseconds singam pipe
to 2.5 that's close to 4x4 little little
work I also suspect that is we're using
two hundred and two hundred thousand
levels for that polygon I also suspect
that the more that grows the bigger the
improvement will be another great tool
really complex is piano it's mostly for
array computation on gpus so in our case
we won't we won't see that much
improvement but it has support support
for acute native optimization it's it's
a project that's being in the works for
for a long time and it's fairly complex
in series in our case we're just not
leveraging it as much it has some
trigger dependencies because it's again
the GPU and acute of stuff are kind of
tricky anaconda will solve it if you
want to play with it that's how i
recommend you you install it you can see
it here but there are in next to this
slide there are a couple things I had to
do to actually get it working on an
iphone too but direct they are heading
on a reveal in any case we defined the
vectors and on the operation as well and
then we we call it so pretty much the
same thing although you can tell by just
syntax it by the syntax here that this
is a much more you know re array DP
oriented solution in case
we go up to 40 milliseconds which is
four times Roman Empire was given us and
much worse than Nam expert but you got
to take into account that this cell much
better than C Python the knife solution
and that with a larger data set and and
with cuda this would look much different
and next comes pi PI we're here leaving
the C Python world pi PI as you might
know it's a just-in-time compiler
following the Python spec that is not
related to to C Python at all what that
means is that things that work in C
Python don't necessarily work in pi PI
as we will see there's not it lacks
support for for some things but it's a
real immature project and it's highly
compatible and what we're doing here is
basically running that same code in and
in the shell I don't know if there's the
pipe I back in for ipython but I chose
to the easy way out which is running it
out on my show and what that means also
is that numbers can really be compared
to what we've been seeing in inside the
ipython notebook because time it is
different from time at timer so we're
only able to compare pi PI with Jai
phonin with C Python with the shell
version of C Python in any case it's the
same code it's the same size of diagonal
polygon and we get on 30 milliseconds
whereas if we run Python we get 2.5
seconds so PI PI's much faster now
there's all
some lump I for pi PI let's call numpy
pie it's a fork of the original to make
it work you can go to that URL it's not
there yet and what that means is that
there are things are missing you can go
to this URL and see what supported and
what's not but in a case for for our
example it works but the truth is if we
we run it we find that it's 10x more
than 10x slower than just the pipe I
version so i guess it take away is none
pipe is work in progress that you know
will let you use your numpy coating
inside pi PI but it's not necessarily
faster at least not for this example I'm
sure you can come up with an example
where it will actually be as fast or
more or faster than then the regular num
pipe and for comparison I again we run
the same script on C Python and sip
iphone is fairly slow and non paying
over C Python is almost as almost as
fast as as the knife version on on
bye-bye again as I was saying time it %
time it inside ipython it's great if you
don't use it i recommend it but it's
also written implementing in a way that
you can't really use it outside ipython
so i had to resort to using timer and
what that means is that the measurements
not that they were too reliable to begin
with but as soon as we start doing this
the measurements are completely off from
from the for me
the book jython is as you can probably
tell Python on the JVM needs the jdk j
DK to install it and when we run the
same the very same script we were
running earlier we get two seconds which
is slightly less than 10 C Python but
obviously much worse than pipe I numpy
and the rest and there is no numpy for
for Jason you can find something called
Jane miracle i think i don't know if
it's maintained the people behind the
person behind Jotham was originally the
person that wrote numeric or one of the
not numeric but america i guess the
original python one but i hear they have
moved on to dotnet if i'm not mistaken
anyway no numpy ford iphone there's
definitely a use case for Python on the
on the JVM it looks like it's fairly
similar in performance s.c Python if you
are ok with the JVM startup time which
is not included in this in this figure
finally for the for the scripts we were
ran on on the shell we've got the
ranking it's Python then guy phone num
pipe I numpy and finally pi PI it's the
fastest other stuff that we won't see
how it performs but that's looming and
and will be around in the future
hopefully is pison high-strung is a new
implementation of complete standalone
implementation of python are being
driven by Dropbox just-in-time compiler
it's built on top of ll
so it's pretty similar two numbas and
parrakeets original approach only door
you're not choosing to do it for the
numerical set of instructions but rather
for the entire language of course that's
a huge undertaking one that day only
them could only a company that size
could tackle this is really really early
so we'll see where that goes but it's
really promising we've got blazed Travis
all event gave a talk earlier on this
track about place so I would go too much
into it but it's also one of the hopes
for for Python and for the future llvm
is onion in the mix there as well and
then Python which is a C++ modern C++
transpiler so it transpires a subset of
C Python some subset of Python actually
probably C Python to modern C++ throw
annotations which is fairly simple as
long as you know the stuff you're using
is supported has support for multi-core
and SIMD instructions and it does a fair
amount of is de optimization and parsing
but it doesn't use it doesn't use a
common back end line such a cell vm they
have chosen to write their own
optimizations there was a talk given by
one of the main committers a PI data
Silicon Valley I recommend you watch
that if you're interested this is kind
of what it looks like so you write your
you write your code and then you prepend
your function with a with a comment that
will will be power
spider transpiler and when all else
fails you your run away or you you see
extensions siphon ctypes eff I
everything but anything but leaving
Python do not defy them and to recap
it's not free so try to avoid it think
first and use the best tool for the job
there's there's a lot of libraries and
tools you can use and it's testament to
the maturity of the Python community and
in some way the ingenuity of the of the
community so try to leverage those if
you can so you can you know keep using
the second best tool for any job which
is of course Python thank you
so have you compared to against doing in
line numpy expressions sorry I mean in
place numpy expressions so the way you
wrote it an umpire you do like three
three or four copies which can easily
write it so it doesn't do any copies by
using in place operations so have you
compared against that have I compared
like how fast would it be compared like
if you write it an umpire so it doesn't
make any Android copies let's see so and
you wrote it down an umpire naive way
yeah you're saying here don't create
yeah I don't create so many temporaries
yeah probably probably faster yeah yeah
so the questions what you having
characters to how much faster the others
oh no I have not and your second
question was so have you done it in this
rifle and sadly no oh the whole goal was
to not leave Python IV right at in in
psiphon it's going to be much faster
like this especially it is this problem
it's so dead simple that it's it's going
to fly but then you're you're writing
sizin yeah but a question would be like
ha how much of this do you lose by not
going out of heightened probably a fair
amount I had it I don't have it in in
this laptop but I had it running in
impure or see and i remember it was
fairly faster in ceda it was at least
one or two orders of magnitude faster
than until I guess naive knew my
implementation so obviously much faster
but then you know then you have to tell
they in turn what siphon is or what C is
right
mine is too hot I easily cyclin and it's
so you cycling thing as a bad thing for
just a second father because you could
infer that right if you add some type of
the patient's signatures proceed with
number and three others would be
imaginable you have some evidence about
the psychic on the quad so the question
is is there a library that leverages all
the type inference ders or reading in
some of these libraries to generate
siphon instead of I'm not aware of one
it's I guess it's an idea someone could
entertain sorry sighs and cries well
yeah that's true the latest versions of
siphon claim dad you don't necessarily
have to annotate everything Python does
something clear close to that so Python
would be like a pretty good candidate to
do something like that but I'm not aware
of something that's already out there so
I have a kind of long question which is
in my opinion optimization is kind of an
operational process like for this
problem the mathematician looks at the
Platonic ideal for the formula and
that's all he cares about but it's a
practitioner the data scientist who
needs his answers tonight who has that
requirement for speed he's actually
running code to produce results and what
I'm curious about is the way that it
seems like people write code is you have
some requirements you write code then
you optimize it then the requirements
change you change the code then you re
optimize it and it seems like some of
these approaches are more flexible than
others like numb expression you showed
seems to only support a certain number
of operations so could you comment on
which of these approaches might be more
flexible in the long run because you
wouldn't want to spend 20 hours with
numba only have to throw it away if the
problem changes a little bit right yeah
definitely so as I said in at the very
beginning
think first try to avoid these things
because anything you add to your code
any any code you write that you know the
best code is the one you don't write
once you start writing coding adding
libraries and adding things that
automatically becomes a liability in
terms of you know code base management I
would say that the best the best if
you're worried about that the best tools
are the ones that are you know annotate
your your coding let you not do anything
else such as number or power key if if
you if you suspect that your problem
will change in in definition but not by
much it's probably safe to say that most
tools will well react the same way if if
you if you had a sudden change of
direction of scope something were you
actually need to change things
dramatically it's safer to you know
safer to be Python the C Python only and
not and you know if you threw money at
the problem like besos want it you're
good to go if you've been using pnu and
have like we're tense verse written and
the new who doesn't support the next
thing you need you're going to be in
trouble so definitely try not to period
and if you do it try to just stay as
close as Python as possible I have one
more follow-up question so from this
operational perspective you might sit
down and say I have five hours taking
right by code faster and I have to pick
a particular approach and we saw
different results with different
techniques like numba didn't really help
that much here but you said it helped a
lot in other circumstances yeah do you
think that there's the same variance for
outcomes for each of the approaches or
do you think that one of these
techniques might give you some speed
some some guaranteed speed up but not
that much and other approaches might
either give you a lot of speed up or no
speed up whatsoever and you could use
that could guide you know how you spend
your time yeah I think there's
definitely a lot of variance and
and that basically is encoded in the
type of problem in the type of data in
the type of computation and you probably
can't escape that with with this tools
because most of them are really
specialized in fairly mature but really
siloed so yeah once you once you go and
once you decide you want to do this the
best way of not working too much is by
trying a bunch of them seeing what works
for you seeing what you want to do
because you know pi PI might be really
fast but I don't want to deploy pi PI on
production because it's a different
language quote unquote so yeah different
definitely a lot of variance and a lot
of difference depending on what problem
you're trying to tackle what's my
favorite put me on the spot huh I really
like gnome expert I think it's really
smart and I think it's really fast
nomics / any further questions okay in
that case in about 10 minutes we meet in
the other room for for the panel
discussion and let's thank all speak of
us more
you